in the meantime today some long lines
outside the convention center this
afternoon as people wait to get the
cobid vaccine this is the second one
yesterday a system failure led to long
wait times at that mega site
workers had to register people by hand
hector mejia live now with an update
from the southern nevada health district
hi hector
hey there well these lines really
stretch as far as the eye can see this
is for the second dose of the
coronavirus vaccine
and earlier this morning i reached out
to the southern nevada health district
they told me that yesterday's issues
were caused by a temporary wi-fi outage
that has been fixed and it's not an
issue today
we're told the system eventually
returned online yesterday and is working
today
the health district is stressing that
walk-in availability is based on clinic
capacity
so if the spots get full they will not
accept additional walk-ins
another challenge the health district
has been dealing with reportedly are the
more than ten
thousand duplicate appointments we've
been telling you about
officials are asking people to cancel
the appointments they cannot make
we talked with some who arrived first
thing in the morning just to make sure
they get the second shot in their arm
yesterday we came at we had a 2 30
appointment we got here
12-ish 1 o'clock somewhere in there and
the lions were
out around just like they are today we
take care of the
grandkids so you know we worry about
them so we want to protect everybody
else around
us also despite the wait the chavez
family told me it was well worth it and
now that they are fully vaccinated
they'll feel more comfortable getting on
a plane with other people once they get
the green light
the latest health district update from
yesterday shows that so far more than
two hundred
three thousand first doses have been
administered and more than forty
thousand
for the second dose and i gotta tell you
we can sense as people walk out the huge
sigh of relief they're walking outside
of this building fully vaccinated
we have a list of the groups that are
available or who are that are eligible
and the locations on our website
eightnewsnow.com
reporting from the las vegas convention
center hector mejia
8 news now